a little video a move that I quite like
and it never occurred to me to make a
video about it until recently when
somebody said what's that and I said
this and they said yes that and I said I
don't know it's just a thing that I
always do and they said what's it called
and I said I don't know so I invented a
name which is cushion reject Christian
reject I have been doing this since Andy
henyk Schmidt Tandy visited me in
Vancouver like in 2004 or something and
he showed me this you sort of back the
hand stops I thought that was really
cool and fun and we geeked out on it and
it became this where you're stalling
both hands pretty simple idea that just
takes some finesse it begins with hand
same direction each poi hits the other
hand which is the tough part for most
people because you need your planes
really straight or even a little
inverted kind of coming towards you
typically one will hit and the other
won't now there's time same direction so
the inward pull will come down hit the
other hand the outward poi will hit the
other hand from the bottom and that's a
breakthrough you you need first so when
they both hit and that's ugly just to
hit but that's how it starts just before
it hits you move with poi to absorb the
movement absorb and with practice you
can absorb further and further until
you're really twisting your arms up it's
a little awkward so I just absorbed to
about halfway halfway and I are like try
to catch the play coming around which
was they say my blue poi inwards as it
comes back up okay at the green one
catch it and the trouble I've never
quite figured out how to what to do with
the other poi so ideally I'd because I'd
like to make it to a perfect one little
wobble and then reverse wobble reverse
catch reverse and why don't the England
and of course just other people I you
know Andy and I were not the only people
to come up with this I've seen lots of
other people invented themselves and
someone even showed me they were where
they took it and they did I wrapped the
cushion I wrapped the cushion air
wrapped the cushion and they could air
cushion cushion really well and I never
got very good at that so I'm sure
there's other names if you know another
name for this move post in the comments
because that's just my temporary name
Christian rejects because I didn't know
what else to call it
these are pot pie with capsules 2.0 if
once in a while come to play play go to
the gear section I'm always reviewing my
favorite gear and there's referral
programs that you save money and Elsa
supports what I deal with and Playboy's
also where you final kinds of other
stuff like photography I do my etc I
hope wherever you are is as pretty as
this
[Music]